do you do the tap oh yeah apparently
that's the thing i don't know what it
does
it does that jesus okay cheers
oh nice that's the stuff no
[Music]
where are you probably i'm from durham
yeah yourself
original from cambridge but i live in
london rice okay do you live in london i
do live in london yes i'm a theater
oh look at that is that nickel's key
yeah it is isn't it yes
what is in equals cakes you know do tell
me
figs is that right it's a small round
pie similar to a turnover filled with
currants and made from fluffy pastry
no figs what am i thinking of that has
figs in it
here we go what do you reckon come on
man i'd see a person to spawn
right so that's a scarlet and that
echoes cake comprendi on that one
however comprende
i feel like we've got some we've got a
hurdle to get over first jesse
what how are you i mean i've gone well
look at that
that was the hurdle i think that's been
out for a while that's hurdle number one
how long
is what do you do first oh oh cream
cause i'm not a complete animal
i'm a jam first and then cream guy i
don't know why maybe just
it's just the northern way potentially
can i try the way you do it i feel like
maybe i should do that yeah get involved
right yeah
okay lovely yeah cheers chin
oh summer's day
that's what we're doing we're going to
go for an apple cake now i'm not going
to cut it
i reckon it's breaking nothing's inside
it's going growing heavy oh that smells
good you know
i think that is thick it's thick it's
big it is
definitely fig google is wrong
so i'm gonna go with scone for me the
south
right i'm doing scone
i actually really like both of these
products should we start with him do you
really want to start with
him yeah okay i feel like i need
something to line my stomach no i can't
get the get them on that
hang on anyway okay right everybody
bottoms up cheers
oh nice and warm oh i mean it's lovely
now it is
it's summer it's something it's grass
festival let's do the smooths because
you've got to say
smooth with a v it's moving it's smooth
do you do the tap
oh yeah apparently that's the thing i
don't know what it does does that
jesus okay don't
that's the stuff no yeah
god again warm but you know
actually to be honest that's one of the
only beers one of the only canned
beverages that you can actually drink
warm and it's
completely i think it tears a bit beefy
like like a beef sandwich and a drink
i mean yeah there's beef sandwich i'd
already had beef sandwiches then no
no but like you're eating like a
mouthful of grass or something uh you
really are enjoying that aren't you i'm
gonna go back to this one i'm sorry i'm
doing me heritage normal pride here but
yeah i mean they don't go well together
oh bad idea
no no no no right okay so who's the
winner
i'm i'm defending the south poorly
look i'm gonna go smith i'm moving down
south and i'm taking your yes
cheers okay grand reveal gosh
do you have some tea yeah you have tea
what you instantly drawn to
the english breakfast are you really
would you go
are you talking yorkshire tea is like
what's the difference
i feel like i almost all my life to
yorkshire tea
i might go straight in just as it is
yeah neat
the neat tea right i'm not in anything
that one tastes like better qual
i'm not convinced you don't know no i do
you owe your life to one of these
that's the twine and that's yorkshire i
mean i do prefer this one
right yeah yeah this just tastes like
sort of hot dishwater
my heart my heart
i just i feel like it's more robust do
you know you probably
actually that tastes like a product this
just tastes like a bipolar
i just prefer that boom
i'm going to have to disagree let's call
it raw
fudge and lick i guess it's licorice
it's kind of similar to licorice it's a
ponte proud
berlin it's salty and horrible it
smelled like petrol
you're going to need a churro for a
while what's the point of it
it's kind of like you know when people
used to chew tobacco on the orleans yeah
it was kind of like the idea like
fisherman's friends that kind of vibe
oh okay that's what i mean guys really
it's in your teeth you need to like work
your way through it
there's a lot of there's a lot of light
it's it's not my favorite thing i'm not
gonna lie
bush a delicacy it's another it's
another northern product that you don't
like i know
i really am not particularly doing well
here this i do like
fudge would you argue for just southern
yeah from cornwall the coast
i'm getting a geography lesson whilst
i'm also here as well because i thought
about northern england
oh of course it is cornish food you know
yeah that's delicious
brilliant that's not bad it's so good i
might have a second piece i'm not gonna
lie
feels like it's like incredibly bad for
you am i a terrible northerner
i probably am i think it's better norton
is
northerners
it's fudge it's the southern beautiful
cornish fudge
am i going to have to give you this one
celestial.com i feel like it is
southern wind you've got to do something
like quasi-northern
acting just to sort of give the
northerners i can't i think we're like
10 mil
i i personally feel like i am the worst
northerner imaginable and i'm sorry
i would like my favorite you've got a
good accent that's all you need thank
you
you've got the charmer northerner even
though you don't know where it is
look at that beautiful thing the
cherry's not even in the middle you're
trying to tell me it's beautiful it's
not yeah but everyone knows what you do
with a cheddar
you pick it out and you chuck it in the
bin does anyone else eat the cherry
i always take the cherry off what yeah
you're trying to defend this snack you
take the cherry off yeah but it tastes
better oh yeah
i'll take off the first four layers it's
not the same bro